[Music]
welcome to a thrivable life a podcast
that shows how Ordinary People can take
everyday actions for a thrivable future
where everyone lives in harmony with
nature hi I'm cavia a project manager by
profession and I am interested in
learning about the impact we have on the
environment in society and in turn how
we are shaping by it and I'm Mike I'm a
research assistant at Thrive with a
background in political science and
social policy I also have a passion for
social and environmental sustainability
and biodiversity and we are from the
Thrive project the not for-profit
Research Institute Think Tank and
advocacy group kavia and I will be your
co-hosts as we talk with our special
guests about how we can create a world
that is not just sustainable but one
that thrives before we introduce this
week's guest we would like to recognize
Aboriginal and torr Islander peoples as
the first people of this place now known
as Australia as well as First Nations
people across the globe and today's
topic is something Our Guest is very
familiar with this is sustainable
agriculture we would like to introduce
today's guest Le llo deini she has a
bachelor's degree in physics and
agrometeorology she has worked at a
science and technology institution in
South Africa she has completed her
Masters in Business Administration at
Edinburough business school in the
United Kingdom and has a special
interest in climate change and
agriculture thank you for joining us
today thank you for having me maybe we
could start by just understanding what's
the definition of sustainable
agriculture in simple terms sustainable
agriculture means farming to meet uh the
demands for food production without
destroying natural resources Land Air
and most
importantly water to irrigate and grow
the crops or livestock that you have on
your I know you uh have a background in
sustainable agriculture how did you come
about getting involved in the space uh
actually the plan was not to uh go in
agricultur sector I actually plan to
study uh matology which was mostly
influenced by my mom because my my mom
worked at matology
to but uh agriculture it's something
that was always there at home my dad was
a a teacher but on the side he plant
crops we had uh a shink and cows
chickens we basically farming on the
side and we will sell to the community
that we have people passing by our house
they see they saying this crops and
animals and then just come and B and uh
like I said earlier the influence was
more of what my mom studied so when I
completed my
metric um I applied University of
Victoria to study materialy but then
there was challenges with Finance
because if I had to go out of the town
that I've stain to go and study in
another Province um it will actually
more expensive so my parents were like
can't you find something similar here at
home that it's related and that's when I
uh looked at uh the university that was
in my area I see that they offer AGR
matology that's when I was like it's the
same it's the same as studying matology
and at home we are doing farming so I
pursued
agrology that way yeah sounds like a
blend of you know what you had seen all
your life and somehow happened very
coincidentally yeah it's it's basically
my childhood everything was they
influen most of my career what do you
see as the need for sustainable
agriculture like why do we need it and
what's kind of wrong with the ways uh
for at least quite some time it's it's
maybe industrially done or it has been
followed uh I think SU
agriculture we have to ensure that we
keep our we protect our resources so
commercial farming it's good in a way
that it provides uh food to people but
now it also compromises on
sustainability compromises on
uh the environment now we have pollution
and using Machinery that requires foral
them so if we can try to at least um
incorporate methods that are more
sustainable providing food still
providing food for people but without
impacting their environment so I think
it's important that uh we we consider
those factors especially for commercial
Farmers they are more on the commercial
side of using more um energy
consuming uh
machinery and so uh it's important they
also focus
on uh bringing that sustainability
aspect in their farming practices and
you did mentioned about I think maybe it
is challenging when you look at the way
agriculture has been done until now uh
in the sense that uh you know commercial
agriculture probably uses a lot more
resources and in cases where even for
example Forest are probably uh being
slowly removed uh to promote certain
products which are extremely high in
demand so in in such a situation of you
know extreme high demand and then uh
just the need for food increasing and
variety of food increasing what are the
different challenges that somebody who's
trying to move into sustainable
agriculture would probably
face um the challenges that I think I've
noticed among fers is um lack of
knowledge
a lot of farmers are not aware of what
sustainable practices are for them to
actually begin implementing that in
their farming
practices and some of them once they get
the knowledge now they are faced with a
challenge of funding how do I now get
the money to get these uh resources that
are going to help me to produce enough
for
people and and uh help me transition to
uh sustainable agriculture shows those
are the
challenges and the other challenges that
uh farmers
face uh when it comes to converting to
sustainable
agriculture is the demand people are now
used to uh conventional way ways of
producing food so now when a farmer
comes and tries to introduce food that
are organically produced
or um they didn't use a lot of uh
chemicals you find that now they are
only at a small percentage of the
community so they're not getting a lot
of buyers so now you find that the
family
like I still think I need to produce for
me to I have a livelihood I still need
to produce my my crops the way the the
conventional way so and uh
sustainable sustainably produced um food
are usually more expensive than
the the conventional produc food so
people normally opt for that and it's
really a challenge for Farmers
so um then those are the main challenges
actually with uh transition to a
sustainable AG
culture yeah and I think I've also seen
uh for example certain organic products
sometimes don't look or are not
sometimes the same size in terms of
specific species that work well as a
conventionally produced one which look
like that pict a perfect in some sense
and I don't know if that also has has an
impact because I have seen people who
might not see a big price difference but
they just don't find it
goodlook enough to buy uh sometimes um
not sure if that's an experience that
you had
too H yes yes I can agree with you with
that and also the other day I I I got
these wipes that said they were organic
and then I realized I have to use them
more than the conventional product so I
thought maybe I would use those less but
now I find myself using more of those
products than the other
ones yeah I just wanted to uh you know
raise as well and question um you know
the the fact when we're talking about
obviously different organic produce and
even as you were saying lot L lot small
scale examples of of like you know
farming you know in a small scale within
a local community but I suppose another
factor is as you was kind of alluding to
the the quality of produce is things
like efficiency and on that commercial
level the efficiency of produce and
meeting meeting demand from the public
and you know having enough of um you
know having enough resources uh you know
products to to to feed a population Etc
and how that kind of intersects with the
you know sustainability requirements on
that kind of mass scale obviously people
can talk about organic F but on that
sort of mass scale I think that must be
one of the biggest challenges in terms
of supplying uh demand within you know
populations broadly and how what the the
sustainability approaches are there so
I'm wondering if that's something that
could be uh noted as as needing more of
a a revision um and you know more of a
comprehensive one as opposed to what is
often cited as as I I've noticed where
people do talk about uh they they might
ignore the need for um let's say
approaches to preventing
deforestation you know
talk about say animal agriculture for
example and the huge impact that that
has on deforestation or water use Etc
but people then point to small scale
examples to kind of say yeah but this
can be done in a way which is yeah more
sustainable but obviously there are huge
challenges given the the fact that uh in
order for
most uh supply for most people uh there
is that well let's say that large scale
commercial need you know of of
agricultural uh for agriculture so I'm
just wondering what the how how we could
address those challenges and and how you
would see that lot Lo the distinction
between or or where in the African in
the South African context how you would
see local or
community-based
produce is that possible to supply
populations broadly or is the commercial
side needed and therefore needing to be
revised in how it's done so it's done
sustainably I think because now there's
more people especially let me speak
about South Africa because more people
are now um in the city we do need more
conventional agriculture to supply uh
food but if people really stayed in
their Villages and not move more to the
city and I I think because what happens
in rural areas and Villages people
plant crops and they have
animals and they would either sell those
crops to the community so you find that
you are think the community
so now the the farmers the commercial
Farmers don't have too much pressure on
feeding the whole population because now
people are also moving away from the
villages to the
city there's a demand now to feed these
people who are in the city who are not
planting crops in their gard and all
that so that's why I think the the
conventional farming has become
prominent that way
so there are still uh small farmers like
for instance for me I always always
tried for Farmers that I can go to to
buy the food directly from themb and now
in find the challenge now with them I
think they also saw okay people now want
naturally grown food and they don't want
food that are
produced conventional way you find that
now the prices are now so high and then
you realize when you compare them with
the the prices at the Supermarket you
realize wow I'm paying twice as much to
get this Natural Glow chicken or
sheep and that also discourages one to
actually um support those small farmers
who are producing sustainably grown
chickens and other
livestock yeah I'm just wondering yeah
in turn the the you know the I suppose
the reality faced with the world at the
moment is the factor of you know our
population growth and huge we've got
what over 8 billion people on the planet
now and suppose that comes into it as
well that like historically you know
thousands of years you know we've been
able to live within sustainable
parameters obviously but uh with that
population growth and supply of food
products to to the population there's
obviously has to be some attempt that uh
because of the huge scale of Agriculture
required there has to have that revised
approach and I think obviously yeah so I
suppose um population is probably a big
part of it as you said so many people
are living in cities but that too is um
you know just our human existence is
generally has a big encroaching impact
on the on the natural world yes yeah on
the demand side I think that's one of
the biggest challenges is having a
market that's accepting organic uh you
know food and also just given standard
of living uh and just struggles with
bunch of crisises we've had in the past
I would say three to four years there is
a you know costs attached to it but
there are other challenges as well that
we spoke about for Farmers U are there
any solutions uh maybe technological
solutions that are actually helping
organic and sustainable practices going
forward are there in examples that you
want to share with us for actually for
commercial even for for sustainable
Farmers um I think now the usest
technologies that farmers are using now
is uh Precision
agriculture where farmers are now using
um drones and sensory devices to
actually detect pirs checking whether
the crops uh the field it has water or
it's dry so it helps them um
improve their farming practices so those
that that is one of the technologies
that I'm
seeing
happening as well as also artificial
intelligence is is really gaining uh a
lot of momentum in the agricultural
sector farmers are using it to get early
warnings of severe weather conditions
like like these days we are having heat
waves and um most farmers are
complaining that crops are drying out so
uh artificial intelligence can help
farmers with um detecting severe weather
conditions like droughts and floods
which normally are some of the factors
that uh influence Farmers production and
artificial intelligence they can also
determine the moisture content in the
soil of the crops that they have planted
uh whether there is enough water or less
water so it improves the improves the
farmer's irrigation system so the farmer
will end up implementing smart
irrigation systems that will let him
know when to
irrigate and when not to irrigate so in
that way they are conserving water so
use water based on what the crop
requires so those are some of the
technologies that are actually improving
the agriculture
sector yeah I think I think that's great
that but there are ways technology can
help especially today with digital
technology moving at the pace that it is
um and are there any actual practices
that the farmers do which which have
changed
from a day-to-day perspective in the
pursuit of being more sustainable on one
hand like you said it's the use of
technology to get certain data U or
watering systems but what have they
probably changed in how they do farming
yes there are other farming
practices that uh promote sustainable
agricultures which uh requires Farmers
to
use less uh machinary less energy and
these are for example no till practices
no tillage so Farm you find that uh in
conventional farming a farmer would use
fossil fuel powered um vehicles to
actually prepare their soil for plant
but no tillage you don't have to use um
fossil fuel consumption Machinery you
just plant uh the the crops directly on
the soil without having to alter or
disturb the soil so no tillage is
actually one of uh the sustainable
methods that some farmers are using to
eliminate um energy
use and there's also crop
rotation Farmers they basically PL
crops uh not at the same area or piece
of land consecutively every year so find
that where you have where the land where
you initially planted uh spinach for
example we now change plant like pnut
watermelon so it also helps retain the
um soil health and not really affect the
composition and the structure of the
soil maybe while while you're at talking
about practices um we can um mention how
does having local products or Market
have any impact definitely yes local
products are actually good because you
find that it takes a shorter time
for to deliver these foods to the stores
to the retail that so it takes quite a
shorter time and the food are fresher
and it becomes less expensive local
agriculture supporting it's actually uh
very sustainable and in some cases if
you buy directly to the farmer you
actually eliminate having to the farmer
having to Now
package um his uh her product so I think
even my my dad CU he
also supplies to one of the local Stones
egg home they don't use packaging like
you see in big retail stores just just
you know fasten it with a rubber band
and it's done it just saves a lot
on packaging material yeah that's
predominantly plastic in most places
it's it's quite insane for example when
you see a banana wrapped in a plastic
which makes absolutely no sense uh no
matter where I think it comes from and I
think one of the other impacts I think
we see that in terms of local products
um correct me if I'm wrong are specific
crops or you know way of farming that uh
promotes uh more sustainable agriculture
yeah it's really uh dependent on whether
the crop can sustain the type of weather
conditions so farmers normally uh they
look at weather patterns and when they
plan for farming in the next year they
okay this year I might not I don't think
I should plan or some in some cases they
don't know what the weather is going to
be like so but
some of them have knowledge about how to
mitigate on these severe weather
conditions so crops like Maz where I
come from in the Free State they
can uh tolerate uh drought they can
tolerate heat heat waves is a big thing
in South Africa these days and
sunflow it's also one of the crops that
um can collect great drought and heat
and there's other crops in other parts
of the world like wheat I think even
wheat and beans they do well in those
conditions so and um yes and uh like I
said earlier farming systems like crop
rotation helps because if you are
planting the same crop every year
it but you might find that uh it's not
going to survive in this year's weather
condition so when you rotate your crops
and not plant the same thing the crop
might do well and farmers can also try
to farm other crops that they haven't
farmed before CU you don't know how they
do in the type of soil your your farm is
or the type of weather
that uh will be there yes yeah I just
wanted to briefly add to that and I just
wanted to yeah briefly add I'm not
certainly not an expert in agricultural
sustainability but yeah one one
interesting Innovation I'm aware of as
llo was mentioning about new crops was
uh or new you know approaches was the um
phenomena recent phenomena of seaweed
farming and just seeing how that has an
extraordinary uh potential at least
because there isn't that requ for
fertilizer or water use you know for it
to grow and it does have many uses
including to supplement plastic you know
bags you know it can be a plastic use as
well as food food source uh for for
different additives as well as protein
but also um it is a huge um carbon you
know source of carbon sequestration so
it's really it's good for climate the
climate and mitigating climate change as
well so that's probably another just a
little interesting point point I thought
to to mention that um going forward you
wonder to what extent that will be uh
embraced given that it has a completely
different uh sort of output and um way
of being produced than most traditional
agriculture obviously on land
anyway yeah yeah and I think yeah Beyond
land agriculture there's also other
other things that we could probably grow
what is needed uh to promote sustainable
agriculture for me what I think uh
consumers can do really to contribute to
sustainable agriculture firstly they
should um focus on eating what is in
season buying what is in season that way
we do not put too much pressure on the
resources in fact we do not put too much
pressure on Farmers to
produce uh crops that are not
season and that also helps the farmer to
not put too much pressures on the
resources because now they have to
produce crops that are not in season
because people now want if people can
just eat what is in season and rotate
crops like that I think it will
contribute to sustainable agriculture
and won't have to put too much pressure
on our resources yeah and I'll probably
just yeah mention um obviously being
just being the consumer to be aware of
of you know the the impact that um some
some agriculture can have on the
ecosystem broadly and um yeah to try and
choose sustainably obviously plant-based
approach is is helpful but yeah to
choose sustainably broadly just to be
aware of things like water use as well
yeah and as well as particular
particular businesses which might not be
sustainable um in the in their
operations as well yeah and I think just
education broadly is not just for
Farmers it's also for for consumers a
lot of times like was saying um and I
think we could also probably focus on
the fact that there needs to be probably
policies and just general promotion uh
something
that people from all walks of life can
kind of come together and try and uh
make a push in their local governments
and their local uh agencies as well to
ensure that there is some kind of policy
and incentives that might help farmers
really um focus and sustainable farming
without losing you know their source of
Revenue yes most defitely yeah and I
think it's also important I remember a
study particularly showing how
incentivizing uh farmers and and having
proper yeah policy guidance by
governments for for uh you know moving
towards more sustainable farming and
particularly where it's particularly uh
the current practices might be
particularly bad but there does need to
be leadership from governments and less
um sort of governments adhering to
short-term economic profits or you know
GDP short-term benefits and looking more
so the future of sustainability and and
guiding both farmers and and consumers
alike in that way and and the people uh
people within the community the
consumers putting pressure on
governments uh to do so and to look at
what is sustainable farming and what
isn't and to put pressure on governments
to lead in that way to to make it E
easier for that transition yes thank you
so much I definitely learned a lot
thanks to and Michael for for talking
together for this much time on this
topic thank you for having
[Music]
me